-Puerto Rico is in the midst
of an epic humanitarian crisis
after being struck
by Hurricane Maria.
Most of the island is
without electricity
or clean drinking water, people
are desperate and terrified,
and the situation is only
gonna get worse
in the coming days and weeks.
So, naturally, President Trump
tweeted last night
that Puerto Rico has an...
and that they owe money to...
Which brings us to a segment
we call "Hey!"
[ Suspenseful music climbs ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
Hey!
Don't go after Puerto Rico
for their financial
problems now.
Victims of tragedy aren't
lookin' for real talk.
You don't start a eulogy
by saying, "Well,
the guy never exercised."
[ Laughter ]
And, hey, weren't you the guy
who was gonna put Americans
before Wall Street?
You couldn't even do that
in a tweet!
People don't have
clean drinking water
and your first instinct is
to tell them they owe money.
What are you, some kind
of [bleep] landlord?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, right,
you were a [bleep] landlord.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Whistling ]
Hey,
thank God -- thank God
you didn't go to Vietnam.
I can see it now:
Trump, I'm hit!
Get the medic!
[as Trump]
You still owe me $20.
[ Laughter ]
And, hey, it took you
a full week
before you even sent someone
to check out the situation.
For a guy with such
a crooked little boner
for first responders,
you sure are the last responder.
-[Laughter] Ohh!
-You're like the guy
who says he'll help
his friend move
and then just shows up
at the end for pizza.
[ Laughter ]
And, hey, Puerto Ricans
are Americans.
They use American currency
and carry American passports.
There's an Applebee's
in San Juan
and Americans in San Juan
go there
to get disappointed
by American food.
[ Laughter ]
You wanted to make America
great again,
so I'll say it again:
Puerto Rico is America.
They're included in the whole
"Make America great again"
thing.
Though, let's be honest,
some Puerto Ricans are already
as great as it gets.
[ Laughter and cheering ]
[ Applause ]
This has been "Hey!"
[ Suspenseful music climbs ]
[ Cheering and applause ]